TREY: WELCOME BACK TO
"SUNDAY NIGHT IN AMERICA,"
APPROVAL NUMBERS ARE THE
PRESIDENT, CONGRESS AND THE
MEDIA ARE TERRIBLE, A VAST
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS DO NOT
WANT TO SEE A REMATCH OF
2020 PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION,
MOST AMERICANS' NEW LEADERS
WITH NEW IDEAS, BETTER
RESULTS, 17 OF YOUR
PRESIDENTS WERE GOVERNORS
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
CURRENT GOVERNORS WITH
APPROVAL RATINGS OVER 50%,
13 OF 15 MOST POPULAR ARE
REPUBLICANS.
SOME ARE WELL-KNOWN OTHERS
ARE NOT.
SOME WERE ELECTED IN BLUE OR
PURPLE STATES BUT THEY HAVE
ONE THING THIS COMMON
RESULTS.
THEY ARE GETTING RESULTS.
OVER THE NEXT MONTHS WE'LL
BRING YOU SOME OF THESE
GOVERNORS, SO YOU CAN MEET
THEM AND HEAR WHAT THEY ARE
DOING AND DECIDE FOR
YOURSELF, WELL LEADING A
STATE IS GOOD EXPERIENCE
WHEN IT COMES TO LEADING A
NATION, JOINING US NOW ONE
OF THE MOST POPULAR
GOVERNORS IN NATION, LEADS
SCENE STATE OF NEW
HAMPSHIRE, GOVERNOR CHRIS
SUNUNU, YOU HAVE LOW CRIME,
AND LOW UNEMPLOYMENT AND
HIGH FREEDOM.
FISCAL PROSPERITY.
HOW HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO DO
IT.
>> LOOK, IT IS HARD WORK.
I'M NOT GOING TO LIE, IT IS
WELL CRAFTED AND TEAM WORK,
IT IS MAKING SURE AT THE END
OF THE DAY THAT PEOPLE COME
FIRST, INDIVIDUALS COME
FIRST, BUSINESSES COME
FIRST, SCHOOLKIDS COME
FIRST, IT IS NOT ABOUT THE
GOVERNMENT.
I CHAMPION THAT LIVE FOR
YOUR DIE SPIRIT AS LONG AS
KIRK WE'RE HERE TO CREATE AS
-- AS I CAN, WE'RE HERE TO
CREATE AS MANY DOORS FORTUNE
FOR YOU, BUSINESS ORCHIDS OR
IT IS.
EMPOWERING FOLKS GIVING THEN
OPTIONS AND EMPOWERING
LOCALS AND LOCAL COMMUNITY,
NOT TOP DOWN, WE CHAMPION
OUR TOWN MEETINGS THAT GETS
THE BEST RESULTS.
AND AGAIN A LOT OF FOLKS TOP
CHANGE, THAT A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS WANT TO COME IN
WITH THE BIG GOVERNMENT
SOLUTIONS.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY
YOU HAVE TO PUT THE
INDIVIDUALS FIRST, MOVE THE
POLITICS ASIDE UNTIL YOU
REALLY HAVE TO GET INTO A
CAMPAIGN, IGNORE POLITICS AS
LONG AS KURK YOU GET WAY
MORE DONE, MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND YOU RUN
ON THE RESULTS.
WE HAVE DONE SUCCESSFUL WITH
THAT MODEL, WE HAVE THE
STRONGEST ECONOMY IN THE
COUNTRY.
ALL THESE WONDERFUL
STATISTICS BUT AT THE END OF
THE DAY IT HAS TO BE ABOUT
THE INDIVIDUAL WITH BETTER
CONSTITUENT SERVICE.
TREY: YOU MENTIONED
POLITICS, YOU KNOW BETTER
THAN I, I THINK REPUBLICANS
HAVE MAJORITY IN HOUSE AND
SENATE, I THINK CALLED
GENERAL COURT IN YOUR STATE.
BUT THEY ARE NOT
OVERWHELMING MAJORITIES,
WHEN I WAS IN DC WE HAD A
HARD TIME GETTING ALL OF THE
REPUBLICANS TO AGREE ON
SOMETHING, DOWN HAVE AN
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY, HOW
ARE YOU ABLE TO GET THINGS
DONE.
>> YOU HAVE TO BE RESULTS
DRIVEN, I AM PROUD OF IN
2020 WE WERE ONLY STATE THAT
WENT FROM DEMOCRAT HOUSE AND
SENATE TO A REPUBLICAN HOUSE
AND SENATE, WE FLIPPED IT WE
WON THE STATES, WE HAVE
ABOUT 220 REPUBLICANS -- 210
REPUBLICANS TO ABOUT 190
DEMOCRATS IN THE HOUSE, YOU
THINK WE'D BE STUCK IN
GRIDLOCK, WE'RE NOT, WE PASS
VERY SUCCESS BUDGETS AND A
LOT OF TAX CUTS AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FOLKS IT
IS NOT EASY, YOU HAVE TO
REALLY WORK WITH FOLKS AND
UNDERSTAND THEIR ISSUES AND
THERE IS A LITTLE OF DEAL
MAKES AND NEGOTIATES, YOU DO
IT WITH A SMILE AND
POSITIVITY, YOU DON'T DO IT
WITH
INTIMIDATION.
EVERYONE HAS A LITTLE BIT OF
OWNERSHIP, YOU GET THINGS
DONE.
TREY: YOU HAVE WON --
REPEATEDLY AS A GOVERNOR IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE.
HOW HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO DO
IT, BUT DOES NOT TRANSLATE
TO NATIONAL ELECTIONS?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW WHEN
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES COME
IN, I TRY MY BEST TO GIVE
GIVEN THE SAME
ADVICE, IGNORE YOUR
CONSULTANTS IN NEW HAMPSHIRE
IT IS PERSON-TO-PERSON,
LIVING ROOM TO LIVING ROOM,
NOT COMING AT THEM WITH YOUR
AGENDA AS A POLITICIAN BUT
COME WITH AN OPEN EAR, THAT
IS WHY I THINK THAT
REPUBLICANS WILLABLE VERY
SUCCESSFUL THIS NOVEMBER,
RIGHT NOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE RIGHT ISSUES, GAS
PRICES AND
INFLATION AND ELECTRICITY
RATES, DEMOCRATS CAN TALK
ABOUT SOCIAL ISSUES AND THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AS
REPUBLICAN AND REPUBLICAN
PARTY WHAT MATTERS TO THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT IS THE
MENTALITY YOU HAVE TO COME
TO NEW HAMPSHIRE, WE HAVE A
RUNNING JOKE IN NEW
HAMPSHIRE, SOMEONE MIGHT SAY
YOU ARE VOTING FOR JOE
BIDEN, AND OTHER GUY SAYS I
DON'T KNOW I ONLY MET HIM
TWICE, YOU HAVE TO KEEP
COMING AND GET TO KNOW YOU,
AND LOOK US IN THE EYE AND
BUYOFF ON YOU AS A
PERSON.
NOT AN INDIVIDUAL, YOU HAVE
TO BE TRANSPARENT AND EARN
THE PUBLIC TRUST.
AND WHAT YOU SAY YOU WILL DO
IS WHAT YOU DO.
PEOPLE
FLUSTERED AND PUT ADS ON TV,
IT TURNS OUT HE WHO SPENDS
MORE ADS ON TV IS THE LOSER,
IT IS BOOTS ON THE GROUND.
TREY: THEY SHOULD LISTEN TO
YOU.
GOVERNOR CHRIS SUNUNU, THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US.
LOOK FORWARD TO VISITING